[موسيقى]
شخص من الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم سوف يتم
التعامل معهم وقبول الطلبات الاجلاء من
قبل السفاره السعوديه
وصولاهم وصولا الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه
[موسيقى]
كيف تمت عمليه التنسيق بين الحكومه
السعوديه والحكومه العراقيه لقد تمت عمليه
التنسيق على اعلى المستويات وكانت رده فعل
سريعا ومباشره جدا من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهذا ما عودتنا عليه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه بانها صاحبه
المبادرات الانسانيه واغلى ما يكون هو
انقاذ النفس البشريه والانسان وهذا ما
رايناه الان شكرا للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه حكومه وشعبا شكرا لكم
لقد خرجنا الحمد لله رب العالمين سالمين
وغطانا الطريق طويل
من من الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان
حوالي عشر ساعات او 11 ساعه
[موسيقى]